c'est quoi son
[Musique]
charge
il est temps de s'ouvrir vers de
nouveaux horizons et parler de films ou
jeux vidéo dont nous n'avons encore
jamais traité gens meurent dans vis
personnellement à la base je vous
envisagez un trois théories sur
labyrinthe ou autrement appelée my
winner malheureusement les théories sont
beaucoup trop folle pour être traité je
pense par exemple à la survie du nude
grâce au coup de poignard de thomas car
ce dernier avait déjà été transpercée
par ce même couteau qui était donc
imbibé du sang de thomas soit de
l'antidote contre les fondus mais trop
tirée par les cheveux
ou bien la théorie que labyrinthes se
situerait dans le même monde que google
games ou divergentes mais trop folle
mouche je préfère donc vous proposer une
seule et bonne théorie qui quand elle
est très probable
amnon donc les arguments mais avant ça
explique on la théorie dans le
labyrinthe de la terre brûlée thomas
veille sur brenda qui vient d'être
soignée de sa blessure face aux fondus
ce dernier trouve une photo appartenant
à brenda qui lui confirmera que c'est la
photo de son frère nommé george
elle explique que tous deux ont passé
des tests mais que malheureusement elle
fut séparé de son erp mano car elle
n'était pas apte à passer les épreuves
al'inverse de son frère qui lui apte fut
emmené par week end donnant intéressons
nous au comic book de labyrinthe
dans ce dernier un certain georges
faisait partie des premiers blogueurs du
labyrinthe
malheureusement et pas piqué et albi
préféra le tuer lors de sa
transformation avant qu il ne fasse trop
de mal il est même enterré dans le
labyrinthe
ensuite nous revenons au film dans le
tout premier opus quand thomas do
inscrire son nom sur le mur nous voyons
le nom de georges barret signifiant
qu'il est décédé
je ne vais pas y passer par quatre
chemins mais le frère de brenda du nom
de georges et est éligible à passer les
épreuves donc celle du labyrinthe
il doit être plus âgé que brenda donc ce
serait pour ça qu'il ferait partie des
premiers blu car malheureusement ce
dernier fut piqué et donc tuer pour
empêcher qu'ils nuisent trop c'est de
georges ne sont normalement pas les
mêmes mais il ya trop de cohérence pour
qu'il soit la même
nick personnes sa vie n'est jamais
décrite même dans les livres il est
seulement mentionné
et bizarrement à comic book sort avec
beaucoup plus de détails sur ce dernier
pourquoi pourquoi mettre plus en avant
ce personnage enfin une dernière chose
intrigue énormément et pourrait être le
seul contre arguments de cette théorie
c'est le nom de georges
si vous ne le saviez pas chaque
protagoniste apparaissant dans le
labyrinthe sont renommés par les noms
des plus grands scientifiques génie et
j'en passe bref les humains qui ont le
plus marqué l'époque thomas anciennement
stephen furent nommé ainsi en l'honneur
de thomas edison
newt pour isaac newton ou ghali pour
galilée et bref vous voyez où je veux en
venir
george est un nom en l'honneur de george
washington il ne devrait donc
normalement peut-être pas s'appeler
ainsi à la base mais bon s'il faisait
partie des premiers blu car le week end
n'était peut-être pas aussi pointilleux
à cette époque
c'est d'ailleurs ce manque d'expérience
qui fit périr george karl antidote était
très loin d'être au point pour le sauver
il se pourrait que son nom n'est pas été
changé et qu'ils l'ont gardé en
l'honneur de george washington
du moins c'est ce qu'ils lui ont fait
croire dans le week end en tout cas tout
est fait pour que georges soit le frère
de brenda enfin qui soit le même et
unique georges
enfin bref vous m'avez compris j'espère
que cette petite théorie vous aura plu
j'essaie de m'ouvrir vers de nouveaux
sujets pour les théories et j'espère que
vous serez content n'hésitez pas
d'ailleurs à me proposer des idées de
films ou jeux vidéo en commentaire sur
lesquels je pourrais faire des théories
je vous conseille de me suivre sur
twitter c'est très important et à vous
abonner à ma chaîne si ce n'est pas
encore fait d'ailleurs suite à des
petits problèmes avec youtube
je n'aime pas trop faire ça mais ils
m'ont recommandé à ce que vous activez
la petite cloche pour ne pas loupé mes
prochaines vidéos
donc je compte sur vous merci à ceux qui
laisseront un pouce bleus et qui
partageront la vidéo c'était argot rock
et que le liner ce soit avec vous
[Musique]